can he do that again for us just we can  see what he did inside that like he  worked for him did he work on it then do  you if he consistently knocks this shot  down his good night to the rest of the  league and his guys like that to make  road trips bus rides plane rides fun  they do not shut up attend a cupola  trying to keep the Clippers quiet with a  three honest behind a Robin Lopez Murray  now backs it out  teas up the 3-ball got it for his  teammates one time seeing George Hill by  himself  this time knocking down the dead  that's the midway point antenna cuoco  doesn't hesitate and he's feeling it  that three is WEP tonight here at  Staples Center  that's how I decided brother's brought a  cousin to